also breaking at this hour a Serial  stabbing suspect is in custody after two  people were killed two others were  injured in a week-long spree all of the  stabbings happened around the University  District Metro identified Christopher  Martell as a suspect saying he attacked  at least four people experiencing  homelessness  and we believed that he was targeting  possibly targeting unhoused females who  are living in the area alone all the  incidents happened near Flamingo and  Maryland Parkway over the past eight  days Martel is facing both murder and  attempted murder charges a UNLV had  issued a safety notification because of  the proximity of the crimes but did  reiterate that there was no threat to  anyone on campus